julie je t'apporte une commande très
importante
il me faut un caramel un bonbon citron
un nougat un an soit un chocolat une
mandarine un bonbon à la menthe rush
chewing gum de noisettes une grave
saucisson une gaufrette au chocolat une
gaufrette à la moutarde un champignon au
sucre mais quand on tend à instaurer ce
la liste tu me l'as portera parce que
françois matin elle était bien solidaire
je tue pas et en retard pour l'espoir
nono casimir justement je raconte est
une autre vous êtes d'accord
alors maintenant je vais vous raconter
une histoire qui est aussi à tôt m écrit
par jean tardieu
ça se passe en angleterre chez un
monsieur très riche qui est un valet qui
s'appelle john john apportait un plateau
sur lequel était un bateau
monsieur assis sur son lit passe à son
habit et d'y poser sa là quelque part je
termine mon cigare
une heure après john rover la fenêtre
était ouverte sur le lit il n'y avait
rien rien non plus sous la plante verte
et rien du tout sur le plateau
monsieur est parti en bateau et voilà ça
alors qu'en penses-tu casimir
c'est une drôle d'histoire dans
l'histoire tu sais moi aussi j'aurais
bien aimé être marin sur un grand bateau
amarré
c'est vraiment un beau métier most hid
ce casimir j'aurais bien aimé tient le
génie assez ma commande
merci je vous dis tu n'as rien oublier
un attend on dit je ne veux pas la
gaufrette à la moutarde
mais qu'est ce qui lui arrive tu sais
pas que julie est aphone mal à la gorge
je peux pas parler aujourd'hui la pauvre
en larzac à une grosse écharpe julie ça
me donne une idée qui va nous montrer
avec un mime un métier que reviennent
les mets faire si je n'avais pas été
marchande de bondo route d'accord avec
toi là et montrez nous ça
allez vas-y je gardais tiens
oh la la
tu sais toi
et regarde vous chercher mais est ce que
c'est vous cherchez vous le dire après
attendait c'est que nos amis lui sont
chez eux
oh là là c'est pas facile
là aussi tout le sait on peut dire un
succès et les geler à ton avis christine
qu'est ce que c'est le métier et nous
montrer julie à battre artiste peintre
et bien oui tu n'as qu'à bien trouvé
vous savez ce qu'on va faire maintenant
les enfants et bien vous allez nous
montrer avec des mimes les métiers que
vous aimeriez faire plus tard quand vous
serez grand d'accord il vous chez vous
ça vous cherchez on y va en jeu qui
commence
jérôme raynier claqué en place vas-y ans
jérôme laporte on regarde bien jérôme à
faire sont minimes
voilà il formidable qu'est ce qu'il fait
regardez bien
[Musique]
je crois que chez eux il y en a déjà qui
ont trouvé mais semblent attendre des
réponses
mon bilan je crois que cela est bien
d'accord
non non non on donne la réponse à
l'iphone il faut laisser aller jusqu'au
bout très bien jérôme c saint jérôme
c'est un fait mais est ce que c'est une
même peintre que j'ai dit tout à l'heure
alors christine julie qu'est ce que
c'était tout à leurs artifices artistes
lettres et jérôme peintre en bâtiment
c'est pas la même chose qui nous ont
fait un maintenant acquis me sandra
sandra et frédéric aller en piste à vue
pour un soir le médecin du travail à mi
temps
ah ouais c'est vrai qu'ils sont très
très beau comme mym ans j'ai trouvé
on peut le tenir non non non on les
laisse on les laisse un petit peu
casimir ne fait jamais fini bon alors je
crois qu'on peut donner
on peut dénigrer réponse dentiste
c'était sa jeunesse à lesparre dentiste
le monde à vinay j'aime aller chez le
dentiste casimir moi ça m'est égal
j'ai pas dedans ah c'est vrai kazimi un
bond qui va maintenant cécile cécile a
laissé s'il voit la nature fait un avec
mireille très bien cécile et mireille ne
me soufflait pas laissez moi deviner
tout seul à s'engager de fumer nuit et
vous savez il fait très très bien en vie
mais elles ne disent rien en faisant
leurs mines et un livre est mort on ne
dit rien moi vous avez entendu parler du
mime marceau les ophones le mime marceau
c'est un très grand mime français
voilà je crois que si la coiffeuse et sa
cliente c'était ça allait le dire
casimir vient souvent chez le coiffeur
toi tu te moques de moi tu sais bien que
j'ai par un push kenzy mille excuses
excuse-moi casimir michel michel allé à
il faut un accessoire regardez bien
michel les enfants voilà elle met une
veste très chaude pour l'île aux enfants
une grande mise enceinte ne l'a pas
avoir froid avec ça allez michel entre
garde au
elle le fait très très très bien michel
aulas c'est un joli métier d'ailleurs
très très joli métier on avait trouvé
les christine durée par un bond qui en
fait un métronome
will et serge à les sergents c'est un
jeu qu'est ce que ça va être ça me
rappelle un cochon rose a jamais
bolligen admirer le admirer le regarder
comme c'est bien ce qui est
effectivement c'est un agent il doit
qu'est ce qu'il fait en ce moment la
commenter c'est ce que tu faisais serge
bon vous aviez trouvé chez vous pour un
autre mine
non christine qui a fait un aller
christine et michel allait bien on va
essayer de trouver ensemble un business
et moi trouver tout ça allait très bien
et christine largarde eh bien je à vous
avez trouvé
j'ai une idée - casimir et une idée pas
aussi à trouver si vous souffrez pas
casimir basquin casimir à chaque fois
des petites routes mais je crois qu'on
lui souffle main par toujours attendez
on laisse christine terminée voilà en
tout cas c'est très bien mis mes seins
c'est facile comme ça oh la la
ouais je suis sûr que c'est ça et c'est
que si je crois que du poids et déjà le
faire ce métier tu as l'air de connaître
très bien c'est ça oui alors - christine
coudun
couturier jacques christine c'était sa
balle s'est fait une fracture hier
encore nous mais bon natalie wood
nathalie nathalie tu nous as fait un
aller et un demi bon ben on attend
encore encore nathalie un cadet la
regardez là et que ces formations qui
font les mines il faut très bien et puis
vous voulez trouver tout de suite en
touchant sa confiance bâtie la dactylo
je crois que c'est un peu plus que
dactylo d'ailleurs c'est pas secrétaire
dactylo c'est ça ce que vous avez fait
plusieurs choses elle tape à la machine
dactylo qu'ils répondent au téléphone ou
si elle prend des notes
donc c'est secrétaire dactylo paraît
bien lourd pervez où les rejets est bel
et bien arrivé à hervé en piste qu'on va
voir ce qu'il aimerait faire et rob est
allé à l'hérésie
on parle pas sûr n'en parle pas pour le
mime chaque mois fénoir québec marc
lacroix s'est passé dans les camps nazis
m boxer ouais frédéric les fabriquera
d'identité bateau axor faute en prix
moyen
foran je crois que c'est ça c'est ça dix
mois et continue quand même continue
quand même c'est l'heure voilà bah oui
oui avec la grande coupe les arts et la
voilà tu si cela ici bon quasi bien dit
dans quoi tu as beaucoup admiré mais
maintenant on aimerait aussi tu admires
et moi est oui alors vas-y mon métier à
voix haute regarde les séries préférées
dans les plats cher à dire que sinon
regardez où ça danseurs mais ou danseur
à l'opéra quasi mur tu te vois en train
de danser l'opéra
[Musique]